foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what's poll question for the final hour
there so you know Connor
yeah we could put up there if we pivot
back to the Celtics a little bit yeah
all right the problem with the Celtics
is the players or the coach
oh boy which it still feels unfair
yes because Joe Missoula shouldn't have
been in this situation to begin with
right but he's in this situation and now
we start to question I mean I had a
problem with not calling a timeout the
end of game four I'm gonna put this on
the players and Steve Buckley joins us
now he's a columnist for the athletic
and he was at the game last night and
buck I you used a word that I used
lethargic like I'm watching the Celtics
and I'm waiting for something
is there something there with this team
that they do get angry and they're going
to come out differently in Philadelphia
well that's a that's a big question and
I I was shocked I was stunned uh that we
didn't see it last night I would have
thought that the manner in which they
lost game four Missoula not calling the
time out smart getting the shot off late
uh uh Jalen not being on uh being on the
other side of the court for the
three-pointer that essentially won the
game I thought they'd come in with this
Mission and they they were lethargic
there was no energy and uh which really
it what really stunned me at the end
during the post game media access was
was tato who whose play I really enjoy
uh he's just a great player saying uh I
guess it just wasn't our night and I
wished I'd put it in the column I put
the quote in there I wished I put at the
very end
I can't imagine Kevin Garnett saying
that after a playoff loss that that
that's that's how high states that team
was versus what we've been seeing from
the Celtics in the postseason What's
missing
uh
I I veteran leadership I know Al Horford
did God's work the other day trying to
see The Sunny Side of what happened uh
in game four and he said it with such
such statesmanship that I believed him
that that he was going to see this thing
and the Celtics were going to learn from
it and so forth and that didn't happen
and I heard what you said about Missoula
yes he was put in a tough spot and yes
he's a young first year coach trying to
coach in the NBA and we know how
difficult that is no matter who you are
or what your resume is uh but this uh do
you agree with you still comes down to
the players if they are going to be
stars or as we say in Boston Stars they
they really have to deliver and they
have not done so what's the Fallout if
they bow out
that's a great question because uh you
don't want to mix sports but the Bruins
and Celtics both went into the
postseason looked upon as teams that
were going to win championships a local
insurance company put out caps that were
and they had a Celtics logo and a Bruins
logo and they were given free to all the
fans going into both teams games in the
playoffs and
just yesterday Montgomery and the Bruins
held a press conference to admit all the
things that he did wrong during the
postseason and then we've got the
Celtics last night if it was just the
Bruins we'd forget all about it if it
was just the Celtics we forget all about
it but if they both lose in the early
rounds it's going to be remembered
here's your Fallout it's going to be
remembered as the year that both the
Bruins and the Celtics spit the bit
just Jalen Brown want to stay there
I don't know uh you get into that whole
mookie bets thing where did he want to
stay do you not want to stay and oh we
couldn't resign him so we had to train
him and uh and and that'll be until
mookie writes his book one of life's
mysteries and uh I I would say the same
thing with uh Jalen
um
I mean Joe Missoula is he going to stay
as the head coach
I would say yes because it would be
embarrassing for the organization they
they put him in as the interim coach and
they were so wildly impressed with the
job that he was doing that at a certain
juncture during the season they they
took a pen and scratched out in the room
and said you are our coach yeah
for them to remove him from that perch
now would be from its management saying
oh we we screwed up we we shouldn't have
done that so soon so maybe they step up
and do that but I doubt it yeah but he
learns from this yeah I wondered about
it I don't know if anybody brought up
him being out coached during the regular
season but now all of a sudden it's
being brought up because he didn't call
a time out or whatever kind of match-ups
the Sixers and Harden and you know all
of those things but
um it just feels like there's a little
bit more of a Groundswell or at least
it's a topic bar about him and the
inexperience and being out coached in
this series any of that is there
validity to that
uh uh the timeout thing was it was a
running thing during the season uh him
not calling timeouts that's not new that
that was people who cover the Celtics on
a day-to-day basis and who will know a
lot more about the X's and O's than I do
I do a great job reading about it and I
more than on more than one occasion uh
there were concerns about
when and how and if and why he called
timeouts uh that it's being magnified
now is because a it's the playoffs and B
that particular non-timeout happened to
be a crucial juncture of a playoff game
uh that they lost so obviously that's
going to explode into prominence where I
don't see an issue and this is going to
get a lot of touch is that he can't he's
too young he's doing he can't coach them
up uh that they're not gonna they're
gonna tune him out because this is the
NBA and it's only five guys on the court
if you've got five stars they're not
going to listen to this kid from Rhode
Island um uh it that may come out later
on but uh that was not a concern that I
had during the season I thought that he
he comes across as very intense
um and and very nerdy on the metric side
of things and uh he just seems to me
like a 21st century NBA coach
Steve good to talk to you thanks for
joining us it's a pleasure take care
that's Steve Buckley cuddleman's for the
athletic at the Sixers Celtics game last
night